he was an ordinary man I pushed to
extraordinary lengths you seen my I
think I have what you are looking for
who is this I don't think it can take
the heat much longer unless of course
you're gonna do something about it
robbed of the thing he loved most we
can't risk your life for an ice cream
bar you don't understand they're
delicious he had only one choice give up
or risk it all he's here here cow in
blue blazes did he get here this summer
I say if he's gonna come let him come
dessert is a dish best I'm do anything
served anything cold one by far what
would you do
look at you you came all this way you
must really love them is that it
everybody loves klondike bars found this
kind ah I thought I knew you